nous sommes à la clinique de l'hôpital
de verdun une partie de montréal où
danielle mccann a longtemps été la
directrice wife tafer roger pas les
petits points blancs par contre pas
étonnant que la majorité des examens de
caréner mans soit fait par l'infirmière
praticienne mélanie baba son médecin
partagent une grande partie du suivi de
madame emond avec d'autres
professionnels je travaille avec des
travailleur social
les frères sociaux avec un infâme à
praticiens ne les ferment cliniciens et
ferment régulières et parfois le
pharmacien c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'interdisciplinarité approche instauré
ici lors de la création de cette
clinique
il ya une quinzaine d'années c'était
avec le soutien de la directrice
générale à ce moment là c'est aussi
trois aces verte de 1,7 à madame
danielle mccann qui est notre menace de
santé actuellement alors cette éclosion
affecte également nous passions qui se
donne yens nikon a été directrice du
centre de santé du sud ouest verdun de
2003 2012
la collaboration entre professionnels
étaient alors prioritaire pour elle et
c'est ce qu'elle veut implanter partout
au québec
alain of art et savoir son cabinet
décombres aujourd'hui on se le dit mais
tu es au clsc de verdun l'équipe de
soins palliatifs à domicile pris par la
journée docteur geneviève beauchesne a
créé cette équipe avec l'aide de daniel
mais cannes en 2009
l'autre côté c'est pas une douleur
dangereuse
une des premières initiatives du genre
au québec qui aujourd'hui encore est un
modèle c'est la force du fameux modèle
verdun c'est que ces services donc à
domicile et en cabinet on était très
encouragée à l'époque de danielle mccann
elle avait réussi à susciter l'adhésion
des employés à ces méthodes
elle décède en consensus elle décide de
façon à ce que chacun lorsqu'il ya
différents points de vue fasse des
concessions pour arriver à un objectif
commun
pas étonnant qu'elle ait convaincu le
collège des médecins
longtemps réticent à céder plus de
pouvoir aux infirmiers et j'affirme
appartient spéciales seront proposées
désertique de problème
adecco a baissé il faut bien que je le
sais qu'ils me téléphoner hockey en
détresse et voulait lambert marchand qui
a travaillé avec daniel mais cannes
n'est pas surpris ça votre seul mode de
gestion aussi les j'aime l'action cdgm
des combats de boxe et en nos propos
mais pourra-t-elle maintenir cette
approche conciliante lorsqu'elle va
s'attaquer à son plus gros dossier ce
cas des années qu en ontario on ne
modifie le mode de rémunération des
médecins qui médecins sont payés par
patient il voit elle veut limiter la
rémunération à l'acte des médecins de
famille pour instaurer un paiement par
patient une idée à laquelle les
syndicats de médecins se sont longtemps
opposés soit très difficile tout étudié
puis 50 ans aucun ministre de la santé
interne va le faire et tous ont dit
qu'il fallait faire à peu près ici david
gêne-t-il est radio canada montréal